one of the things that really opened my
eyes is on that deployment and really on
previous my previous deployments through
my whole career the army and the marine
corps
had absolutely professionalized and
doctrinalized how they trained leaders
so
the the the army
the army would go to this uh the the
company career course the career course
they call it which is a company level
commander
and this is like a six month or a
year-long school that these guys would
get trained on how to lead their troops
and they have that at every level
enlisted and officer in the army and in
the marine corps
and in the seal teams there was almost
nothing there was almost nothing there
was a little junior officer training
course that was uh leif ended up taking
it over when he took it over it was hey
this is where you're gonna learn how to
write evaluations this is gonna you're
gonna learn a little bit about writing
navy navy message traffic it was
and you'd get some debriefs on some
stuff but you weren't going to actually
learn
any principles of leadership
and it was just it was unbelievable
that this was taking place and i
remember as i started to try and push
this hard
the i went i started going up my chain
of command and one of the things that i
bring up the chain of command was was
hamburger university and hamburger
university if you don't know
it's up in
um
i think it's in schaumburg illinois but
if you're going to run a mcdonald's
you've got to go to this this course and
it's like a six-month school that you go
to
and so i i remember sitting down with my
boss and saying hey have you heard of
hamburger universities and what's that i
said it's if you're going to run a
freaking mcdonald's
you're going to go to a six-month
training course on how to lead a
mcdonald's where you flip burgers and
fry french fries and we've got guys that
have are going to go out and and oversee
combat operations and have lives at risk
and we give them they don't go to any
school
this is a problem and and and part of
the problem is because
we're a victim of our own success so hey
you know hey jacko you just went on
deployment you came back you did a good
job you were in charge okay so what
we're doing is working
and hey this other guy you know leifa
you you did good you got mentored and
you got trained up so that what we're
doing the on-the-job training works
and and it does work sometimes
but it but it also fails sometimes and
this is so now we find this in every
industry every industry hey oh we
we got we got echo charles here he's a
good salesman
in fact he's our best salesman let's put
him in charge of sales
what does he know about leadership he
knows how to sell stuff he doesn't know
anything about leading oh we got echo
charles here he's our best
he's our best mechanic
okay great what are we gonna do let's
put him in charge of all the mechanics
he's good at turning the wrench he's not
good at leaders leadership and we just
throw him in there and for some reason
people think that leadership is
something you're just born with or that
you you know how to do in intuitively
and it's just factually not true so what
we encourage and what you're actually
doing is oh echo
you're the best mechanic
we're going to take you and we're going
to elevate you into a leadership
position and we're going to train you
how to lead just like at one point we
trained you on how to turn wrenches and
repair this carburetor we're we're gonna
we're gonna train you the same way
and you've put a massive amount of
investment into your leadership
and
one of the earlier questions you know
when we started echelon front you know i
get asked well how are we gonna
how are we gonna know if this works what
are the metrics to know if this succeeds
and i still to this day i just had this
conversation the other day
whatever metric you're running at your
company that means you you are
successful so whether you're trying to
cut the cost to produce or you're trying
to improve your time to produce or
you're trying to grow or whatever metric
you're looking at
if we do our job training your leaders
that metric all those metrics that
you're trying to improve on they are all
going to improve that's what's going to
happen
and and that's where you say hey look we
actually have we do some of these like
you know soft skill surveys now and you
know what do you think your leadership
and that's good too that's good feedback
it's good feedback to say hey the
leadership is now has a better
relationship with the troops that's
great the troops think the leadership is
more in tune with what they're thinking
and what they're saying those are those
are great things to do as well
but
for me where the money for the rubber
meets the road is hey we're trying to
produce this widget in this amount of
time and now we're doing it we're
cutting our costs we're getting it out
our sales people are doing better that's
how we measure leadership success is
what is the success of the company so as
you you invest you get that roi
and that's what i you know that's what i
love about seeing the success of your
company and some of the other companies
that we work with that
we get to see this this incredible
growth and you know i started this whole
thing off saying leadership is the most
important thing on the battlefield in
business and life and to look at a
company like yours where you are proving
how that works
and how important it is
and how you can grow things and how you
can have
4 200
employees and i'd love to uh you know if
you were fishing for a compliment say no
but matt it all starts with you hey it
does i'll give you a compliment it does
start with you but let's face it
you've got employees that haven't seen
you in three months you've got you've
got someone right now making a decision
in a basement 100 percent on
on something that's happening and and
that individual is making the right
decision as a leader on the front lines
he's empowered to do that and you
you couldn't see that if your life
depended on it you couldn't help that
person make that decision
except for the fact that you already
have helped them because you trained him
as a leader they understand the culture
they understand the mission of the
company and when you do that it allows
you to to to drive a company forward
with people at every level leading
making the right decisions and moving in
the same direction strategically